I was just in awe I mean I really had no
words I still don't have any words I'm
still in shock 11 months later
that Clark County teacher accused of
stealing from the district and then
cleared is set to return to the
classroom next week thank you for
joining us at six I'm Brian Loftus I'm
Denise Valdez Clark County Prosecutors
declined to pursue charges against Roy
Goodell while he calls it a relief he
vehemently denies any wrongdoing and
wants to clear his name Joshua paguerra
on this story live in the studio with
the interview you will only see on 8
news now now 10 years ago Roy Goodell
began teaching for the Clark County
School District he says he was mission
driven feeling passionate about helping
kids that all Came Crashing Down last
year when he was arrested for grand
larceny and theft
and just giving my time and giving my
care to education and to kids
what happened on March 4th was just
being blindsided Rory good though is
recalling the day he was asked to leave
his office at Silverado High School then
placed into handcuffs the gut feeling
inside to someone thinking that I could
do something like that or be involved in
something like that is
it's heartbreaking it's just it's just
heartbreaking CCSD police accused a 49
year old of obtaining money or property
on the false pretenses grand larceny and
conspiracy to commit theft and stemmed
from his time at Sierra Vista High
School where he was the football coach
among several allegations he was accused
of giving away an iPad and forging a
four thousand dollar invoice I'm not
guilty of anything I didn't do anything
and that has come out the charges were
never pursued when I asked him why he
says he doesn't know I reached out to
CCSD and they declined to comment now
it's just time for me to get back to
work it's time for me to get back to
doing what I love and that's teaching
kids between working in Montana and CCSD
Goodell has taught for 25 years his last
position was as vice principal of
Silverado High I've been a principal
I've been a teacher I've been a coach
you just don't throw 25 years away they
tried to throw it away for me but he is
trying to move forward now with the
district and follow his passion of
teaching students is this a relief for
your family
like that now you can move put this
behind you I think my family like like I
said before I think it is a relief that
we can put it behind us but they they
know that none of it was true
now Roy Goodell says he and the district
signed a settlement agreement that
allowed him to return to the classroom
Brian
thank you Joshua Goodell starts back
again with the district on Monday no
word yet where he will be placed the
district tells us that it can't comment
on employment matters